for the entrepreneur who's getting
started and trying to build this to
full-time business or for the
entrepreneur who's early in a full-time
we're trying to get to that next step
what are some of the tips that you would
give them on how to be productive well I
often ask my entrepreneurs I say why do
you get up and go to bed in the morning
go to work in the morning what do you
get out of bed and they say they think
about it for a while and I said well the
answer is mmm which means make more
money you don't go to work to make less
money or to make the same money you
would have bet you go to work to make
more money so I said no how do you make
more money well it's called SMS and that
means sell more stuff and so you mmn by
smsing now if you are not selling more
stuff in the course of the day then you
might as well go home to bed covers up
over your head to go back to sleep
because you're of no value to yourself
or anyone else and then I start to point
out I notice it I'm going to learn this
from a very successful man look around
your office all right look all right
drop know what don't you see in your
office and the answer is you don't see
any customers all right so why are you
in your office there's no customers
there you can't sell more stuff and if
you think you're going to sell more
stuff by sending out tricky email
messages then you probably need some
medication or a checkup from the neck up
the only way that you sell stuff is you
go out there and you talk to customers
and you ask them to buy it and so if
you're not out asking to buy it now what
are the three keys to selling more stuff
they are prospecting presenting and
closing prospecting means finding new
people who can and will buy and pay in a
short period of time and then telling
them presenting that your product or
service and why it is the very best
choice for them now and then closing
them again to make a decision today this
minute so therefore all come together is
prospecting presented and closing is how
you sell more stuff which is why you got
out of bed in the first place now so
they interview the interesting point
because I've been through all of this
myself they've interviewed entrepreneurs
and they say how important our sales to
your business and the entrepreneur say
oh most important thing of all Oh sales
blood to the
rain oxygen you know to the heart
without that there's no there's no
business I say okay well next question
the researchers asked is how much of
your time in the course of the day do
you spend selling selling more stuff and
they say oh all day long but all I do
it's all I think about it get up in the
morning think about it all day and so
then they said well all right you might
we follow you around with a camera and a
stopwatch for 30 days and just see how
you actually use your time no problem no
problem at all you know what they found
out the average October spends eleven
percent of their time prospecting
presenting and closing whether the other
eighty-nine percent is spent excuse the
expression [ __ ] around they doing fun
things easy things checking their email
checking their email against and it
helped emails they're making phone calls
their those checking their spam they're
spending so much time fifty percent of
working time today's wasted if they're
not checking email the chatting with
their friends the chatting with their
buddies in there drinking coffee and
they're having lunch and they're going
around feeling like big shots because
they've got their own business but the
fact of the matter is if you're not
prospecting presenting and closing you
might as well go home to bed because
you're of no value even worse you're
probably a detriment to other people
because you're stopping them from
working by talking to them or sending
them email or keeping them busy email
according to the Harvard University and
up three studies I've read this week is
killing entrepreneurs because they can't
stop they have this irresistible almost
like an addiction to electronic
interruptions and they can't stop and so
just yesterday Wall Street Journal have
this great article which is what I've
been saying for the last five years is
turn it off don't turn it down turn it
off check it every two to three hours
and then turn it off Oh what if it's an
important message what what you do is
you say this I check my email three
times a day if you've sent me an email
between those times I will get back to
you as soon as I can if this is an
emergency phone this number and the
phone will never ring and then what you
do is give you 3 3 20 min of phases a
day first of all you do for your first
check is a 1030 or 11
do not check your email in the morning
because that immediately addictive and
you're on email all day long so you wait
til 1030 or 11 check it once wait till
two o'clock check it again wait til 430
check at the third time on and off in 20
minutes and shut it down if you can do
that you'll double it triple your
productivity and that's one of about a
hundred ideas that I can give you but if
you'll just do that that'll do more to
help you to be successful in selling
more stuff because if you're not wasting
all this time doing that you have only
one choice is to sell more stuff talk to
customers talk to people and ask them to
buy your product